size of the price is going up i think
you're going to see you know billionaire
content creators
um because they're billionaires and they
go into content creation or because
they're content contributors
um and so like i think it's hard i don't
i wouldn't say it's the easiest way to
become a billionaire
in the same way that like you know for
athletes who's the closest do we think
so let's run through some possibilities
okay i think that the people who you
would think like a mr beast
uh who's like you know one of the
largest youtubers and seems to be making
moves here and there
i don't think it's going to be them why
why not why not them
interesting i don't think so because i
think that
um it depends it's not just about size
of audience
and so you have youtube where there's a
different king every
you know sort of like a few years same
thing happens on twitch ninja is the
best
and then tifu is the best and then now
there's like new people who are the best
so there's just like rotation
um that happens as far as like um as far
as that goes the second thing is
who has the ambition to do it so um i
know that those guys you know through
knight media they're investing
they're doing different things that's
good but i think they have to have the
playbook
and so i think joe rogan either will get
there
or could get there so single person
uh you know sold the meteorites to the
podcast for
reported you know 100 million dollars i
don't know if that's a year or that was
a lump sum
i think they didn't say on purpose yeah
because they want us all guessing
yeah but i would believe that he can get
a hundred million dollars per year
doing that right now he was doing 30
million in ad sales the year before
so right you assume that you know 100
million is probably close
then what else did he do so he created
uh or he's like you know a partner or
co-founder of
on it i don't know what what percent he
owns but
now he's gone into like a supplement
supplements can be a very very big
business right so like you know
uh the rock releasing protein powder is
gonna work
to a degree that like other stuff won't
so these influencers are realizing
why should i shout out these random
brands for
you know cash when i can either create
my own brand or own equity
in i'll demand equity so lebron did this
right lebron was sponsored by mcdonald's
and he's like hey first of all like i
don't eat mcdonald's so this is like
kind of [ __ ]
uh but secondly like i could invest in
blaze pizza
it's like a chain that's growing and
like i can own a significant share of
this just by being lebron like
i want to be on the equity side of the
game rather than being kind of a cash
you know a cash guy and so i think you
have to shift the business model so i
think what we're going to see is
somebody who
creates they get a big enough audience
then
they parlay it through the higher value
uh possibilities so here's some higher
value possibilities
buying businesses i think there are
plenty of uh like for example
fintech companies that build a product
they build a neo bank they build a
credit card a debit card
and they don't quite make it so they
don't quite get the escape velocity
because they're trying to pay for ads on
facebook to get customers they don't get
all the way there
now what if you're what if you're uh mr
beast and you decide to
pick up that company so you buy out that
company you own you know you buy a 100
essentially
you buy the investors out for 10 cents
on the dollar because they're
they're going under so you take that
same technology but you have the
distribution where you're going to get
an
unfair distribution advantage and you're
going to get a million people using the
debit card
just the way that debit cards work debit
card you're going to be able to take
a one percent fee on transactions so you
get a million people spending 100
a month on on this you're gonna be
making tens of millions of dollars just
off that you're gonna be valued at you
know hundreds of millions of dollars
as of with a fintech product and so i
think people who basically launch
financial products people who buy out
businesses that are already doing good
and take them to the next level
using their fame or they go into
categories like
supplements you know um chips
like water you know like these like
large consumer plays because if i have a
big
loyal audience and they want you know
whatever cbd
whatever these like kind of products are
cbd is a great one because cbd you can't
advertise on facebook and google
so uh you can't run ads but you can be
an influencer talking about cbd
and so today they all do cash deals but
the ones who launch branded
you know like fully owned products and
take that seriously they're going to
build a big business in the same way
that like
you know whatever 50 cent made more of
his vitamin water you know proceeds than
he ever did as a rapper
and i think you're just going to see
more and more of that so guys are going
to crypto and things like that
so i agree with some of this and i
disagree with someone who's on the
people
okay i'm going to give you a couple of
examples of people who i pretty sure
are built some of we know for sure
billion or some are that are content
creators
kanye west billionaire content creator
right different type of content sure
music
more traditional yeah kardashians i i
don't know how many there were
billionaires at this point but they're
at least two yeah yeah yeah there's
being reports and uh they're like pomp
brothers right like they just keep like
mormon keeps showing up
[Laughter]
uh then somebody that everyone always
forgets about
is howard stern right he reportedly gets
paid almost 100 million dollars a year
uh and he's been doing it now for years
he's wrong right like
the guy's got to have over a billion
dollars right almost unless literally he
pissed it all away doing like ridiculous
things he's got to have a billion
dollars
uh so those are like three that i think
are uh are pretty simple
so the only caveat so totally agree the
only caveat i would say is
in my lens that i'm thinking through is
uh digital natives so
so somebody who's essentially born and
built they're following so those all get
disqualified because they're more
traditional
yeah so like kanye you know he's got
like a he had like a label and like you
know this is like
he is a content creator but uh i think
when most people think content creator
they don't think professional musician i
think they think more like
youtuber uh or tick-tock okay whatever
so next
is rogan i don't think he ever becomes a
billionaire because i think he's missing
the one thing
that you mentioned which is the ambition
to be
a desire yeah right and he's smart and
wise enough to realize
it doesn't matter he's got enough yeah
exactly uh and i think that the
spotify deal uh whether it'll ever be
said publicly or not
was uh kind of a cash out and uh i'm 50
plus years old if he's 53 54 years old
right i want to spend time with my
family
i'm gonna move to austin um i'm out of
the like rat race right uh yeah sure you
want to give me a hundred million
dollars like
you know fools right yeah give me 100 by
the way i'll keep producing the content
like i enjoy meeting and talking to my
friends whatever
it's cool uh but i definitely think like
that was a signal of the level of
ambition right
um and that might make him the smartest
one out of everybody
like the ability to say i don't need to
go try to be a billionaire right right
uh and then mr beast i actually think he
will do it i think he has the ambition
to do it
uh but i think that what drives him is
very different right it's kind of like a
sam bankman free i don't know how much
you know about him from ftx but like
jimmy doesn't want to be a billionaire
because he thinks it's going to be cool
to be a billionaire right he's not
looking for a yacht he wants to just
give it all away right he wants to help
people he genuinely enjoys doing that
and so like the passion comes through
and like there's a
financial goal because that will help
empower the passion right right
and so i think that like that's like a
very uh unique
driver of i want to acquire a lot of
financial assets
and then like go along give away i don't
know how much money he's giving away but
like it's got to be tens of millions of
dollars at this point
right like pretty incredible for a kid
who's like 25
right right like like that's not a thing
that 25 year olds think about most
people talk about how much they've made
he's like i've given away more than
you've ever made yeah it's like it's
very very very unique now when you bring
it to
um kind of like people that we don't yet
know of
i actually think most of the blinders it
sounds like you're saying this is like
you built the audience and then you
build a company
yes and so yes you are a content creator
but like really you're an entrepreneur
yes and i think it brings this whole
conversation full circle of like all
this is is just they're entrepreneurs
right